bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
journal sur TVfil 78 et dans l'actualité
locale de ce 14 janvier 2015 les
Yvelines en plan Vigipirate attentats et
force de l'ordre sont très présentes
nous enverrons les conséquences sur
notre quotidien
le président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
dresse sa feuille de route pour 2015
Michel logier vient d'adresser ses vœux
il est l'invité de ce journal et puis en
culture retour sur le passage de la
troupe de danse Pokémon crew attrape ce
week-end une troupe qui fait référence
dans le monde du hip-hop
ce matin il fallait se lever tôt pour se
procurer ce nouveau numéro et je sais
que ça fera forcément des envieux de
Charlie Hebdo l'hebdomadaire tiré
initialement à 3 millions d'exemplaires
pour l'occasion et déjà en rupture de
stock il paraît aujourd'hui dans une
vingtaine de pays traduits en 5 langues
au vu de longuement du public la
décision d'augmenter le tirage à 5
millions a déjà été prise que
pensez-vous de cet engouement autour de
la mise en vente de Charlie Hebdo
aujourd'hui vos réponses avec ce
micro-trottoir j'espère qu'elle sera pas
uniquement sur casserole sur sur le long
terme voilà mais je pense que les
réaction salutaire il faut que Charlie
Hebdo continue il y a beaucoup de gens
qui se disent être leurs amis alors
qu'ils n'étaient pas avant après c'est
terrible ce qui s'est passé et il faut
rester unis pour pour que ça n'arrive
pas mais dire qu'on est leurs amis alors
qu'on les pages je trouve que c'est
ça enlève un peu le
c'est une belle journée voilà que tous
ces défilé que on espère que ça dure
voilà mais bon
c'est triste pour les familles je pense
que c'est une très bonne chose d'une
part parce que c'est terrible ce qui
s'est passé chez eux et puis que c'est
important de leur montrer notre soutien
par rapport à ça et aussi pour défendre
les valeurs de la République est-ce que
vous comptez acheter le nouveau numéro
j'essaye mais j'en trouve pas
il est là le nouveau numéro dernier
numéro de Charlie Hebdo il devrait être
disponible à nouveau dans les kiosques
des demain bonsoir Michel legier et
bonne année à vous tout d'abord
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin je sais
pas si vous avez réussi à vous procurer
ce numéro de Charlie Hebdo et non
malheureusement
collègue il faut que je veille à ce
numéro il ne quittera pas splato on lui
rendra tout à l'heure en tout cas je
vais essayer de l'avoir puisque j'ai
souhaité que la ville s'abonne à Charlie
Hebdo donc j'espère le recevoir si il
n'est pas substitué dans les
la triposto vous êtes venu ce soir à
nous parler de cette cérémonie et de
vœux qui s'est tenu hier c'était votre
première cérémonie de vœux en tant que
président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération pour la première fois en
40 ans un président de droite c'est donc
exprimé à la tribune qui avait-il de si
différent entre votre discours en tant
que président et celui de vos
prédécesseurs de gauche sur quoi
avez-vous souhaité mettre l'accent pour
insister sur une différence je pense que
déjà c'est plutôt à vous à le dire
puisque vous étiez dans de dans le
public dans c'est plutôt à vous à savoir
aussi ce qui change en tout cas moi la
dynamique
est différente de celle de mon
prédécesseur parce que d'une part on est
dans des situations contraintes
aujourd'hui comme je l'ai dit d'ailleurs
dans mon discours j'aurais préféré te
président il y a 10 ans là tout était
possible contexte économique plus
difficile exactement ben le contexte
économique et puis aussi surtout le
désengagement de l'État sous la pression
du gouvernement donc aujourd'hui nos
budgets ne sont plus les mêmes on a déjà
des impacts forts dans chacune et des
communes de Saint-Quentin mais la
communauté de agglo bien sûr
à cette règle maintenant et donc
aujourd'hui plutôt que de parler de
dépenser plus il faut surtout que l'on
pense aujourd'hui à faire de des
économies importantes puisque les
budgets ne sont plus isolés même la
priorité c'est l'économie justement vous
nous disiez voilà on était présent dans
la salle on a entendu votre discours
effectivement ce qui ressort c'est les
économies à réaliser malgré tout il faut
garder la croissance à 50 ans en
Yvelines comme on réussit à la fois
booster l'économie sur 50 ans en
Yvelines alors que le contexte et l'État
se désengage aussi booster l'économie
des gestes c'est que la Communauté de
l'agglomération est propriétaire de
fonciers donc appartement nous avons du
foncier nous pouvons encore attirer de
nouvelles entreprises c'est quand même
les entreprises qui font la richesse
d'un territoire et ensuite grâce à cette
richesse ce que l'on dégage on peut
s'occuper de faire venir de nouvelles
populations ou de pouvoir accompagner
les populations qui sont déjà la
nouvelle des entreprises entraîne aussi
de pouvoir accueillir bien sûr de
nouveaux logements mais l'un ne va pas
sans l'autre qui concerne les
entreprises on peut citer à safran sur
le secteur de Magny-les-Hameaux
Châteaufort il y a Baxter aussi
qui commencent encore Rafa qui
continuent à se développer puisqu'il y
aura 20000 m² supplémentaires donc ce
sont quand même des éléments forts et
puis il y a aussi tout ce qui est
innovation tout ce qui est aussi
universitaire tout ce qui est
anciennement supérieur avec l'arrivée
prochaine et la prochaine rentrée donc
en septembre de l'ESTACA et puis aussi
avec le travail que nous faisons pour
l'arrivée de l'École des Mines aussi
juste à côté de safran sur
magny-les-hame mais les entreprises pour
qu'elles viennent s'implanter à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines aujourd'hui
vous leur dites quoi quels avantages
vous leur accordez quelle équipe mon
vouloir promettez parce qu'il y a
forcément une forte concurrence entre
les différents bassins ne serait-ce
qu'en Île-de-France pour attirer ces
entreprises alors il y a différents
bassins sauf que il y a des bassins qui
sortent en devenir nous c'est un bassin
réel qui existe déjà nous avons quand
même même si nous demandons encore plus
mais une desserte ferroviaire qui
même si elle doit être améliorée nous
sommes quand même au bout à la sortie de
l'autoroute A12 nous sommes le long de
la N12 de la A86 donc nous avons pour ça
j'allais dire car même des atouts
importants et puis même si je ne
souhaite pas fusionner avec les soldes
en tout cas je suis à fond dans le
cluster Paris Saclay donc ça aussi c'est
une c'est une force et puis on est aussi
un territoire redevenir puisque nous
travaillons avec sur l'arrivée de la
ligne 18 de métro qui tiendrait
permettre voilà dans le cadre du Grand
Paris donc nous serions sur l'axe qui
desservirait Orly Versailles jusqu'à la
défense justement on va en parler de
cette fusion en tout cas de cette
non-fusion avec l'Essonne parce que vous
ne la souhaitez pas dans le cadre de
l'élargissement de l'agglomération de
toutes les agglomérations d'ailleurs
puisque maintenant le seuil a été
réhaussé ce sera la priorité pour cette
année commencer à préparer
l'élargissement de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et c'est
déterminant pour continuer sur projet
pour booster l'économie il faut faire
les bons choix exactement vous savez
c'est ce que j'ai dit le dossier
principal on dehors bien sûr de
l'élaboration d'un budget c'est
connaître notre futur périmètre soit on
existe encore soit n'existe plus donc
aujourd'hui on a pu d'autres solutions
que de dubattre nous élus et surtout les
élus qui siègent à la commission
régionale pour imposer un périmètre qui
nous semble le plus adapté et donc moi
je souhaite que Saint-Quentin bien sûr
soit un territoire redevenir bien sûr
que nous devons être conformité avec la
loi c'est-à-dire avoir une interco à
plus de 200 000 habitants et pour cela
moi je propose que nous fusionnons avec
la communauté de communes de l'Ouest
parisien c'est-à-dire plaisir les clés
vilebreux ainsi que intégrer les
communes de Maurepas et de Coignières
peupro on est quand même dans finalement
l'ancien périmètre de 50 ans en Yvelines
et en tout cas là je pense qu'on est sur
un vrai bassin de vie on est des vrais
équilibres mais je vois pas ce qu'on a à
faire franchement avec les communautés
d'agglomération de l'Essonne puisque
justement pourquoi vous dites vous
n'avez rien à faire avec les sommes
alors que vous souhaitez développer les
collaborations dans le cadre de
Paris-Saclay non mais on peut avoir un
partenariat sur quelques sujets précis
mais on n'a pas à fusionner c'est à dire
toutes nos compétences les mettre dans
ce même panier est-ce que vous nous
voyez dans une inconnuité à 800 000
habitants c'est complètement aberrant 57
communes à cheval sur deux départements
donc là on est on est loin de
l'agohérence on est loin de la proximité
regardez aujourd'hui ce qui se passe en
France c'est la solidarité c'est la
proximité qui compte or là on nous
éloigne donc moi je suis pour la réforme
territoriales à condition que le côté
proximité des habitants demeure
justement peut-être pour vous faire
réagir le centre de recherche politique
de Sciences Po a remis son baromètre de
la confiance politique dans les
institutions on va voir ce baromètre
s'afficher il en ressort que 66% des
personnes interrogées font confiance à
leur conseil mun principal c'est plus
quatre points en un an et seulement 23%
des personnes interrogées qui font
confiance à leur gouvernement c'est
l'importance de la proximité de
l'échelon local justement
de cette étude donc ce que vous venez de
dire là bien c'est tout à fait les
propos que je tiens je suis dans la
proximité et c'est exactement ce que les
habitants attendent dans les demandes
que les habitants ont sur cette
cérémonie de vous qui s'est tenu hier
par exemple aux personnalités qui sont
venues vous voir je pense que la
meilleure des réponses les lieux il y a
9 mois c'est-à-dire une élection
municipale c'est là que vous êtes au
cœur des réalités d'un territoire donc
les élections municipales on fait voir
que les habitants étaient très attachés
à leurs élus locaux très attachés à leur
mère et c'est justement c'est cette
proximité qui existe encore et c'est
celle-ci qui en plus la plus difficile à
assumer puisque là vous n'avez aucun
fusible là vous êtes directement avec
vos habitants où vous savez répondre où
vous ne savez pas répondre sur la
question de l'intercommunalité juste
pour conclure quel sera le calendrier le
1er janvier 2016 le 1er janvier 2016
nous serons dans un nouveau périmètre
alors comment ça va s’échelonner quels
sont les grossesse d'ici 2016 déjà un
premier rendez-vous le 22 janvier donc
avec la réunion de la commission
régionale de coopération intercommunale
avec le préfet de région donc là on va
encore débattre on va faire nos
propositions sauf que aujourd'hui le
préfet a présenté son schéma il ne le
touchera plus les seules modifications
qu'on peut apporter ce sont les élus
eux-mêmes de cette commission qui vont
devoir présenter des amendements or si
on veut nous avoir notre schéma celui
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure il
faut que cet amendement soit voté aux
deux tiers de cette commission et donc
aujourd'hui on travaille avec les élus
pour faire en sorte que on soit respecté
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui le grand
Saint-Quentin soit affirmé que verse
grands-parks souhaite intégrer Vélizy
donc les choses aussi là sont très
claires et que sur de toute façon les
deux communautés d'agglo qui existent
ont voté à l'unanimité leur fusion entre
elles je reviens à cette cérémonie de
vous qui s'est déroulée hier vous avez
mis vous avez souhaité mettre en avant
des projets dans chacune des communes
des sept communes et même des communes
de gauche j'ai envie de dire c'était une
façon de montrer qu'aucune commune
n'allait être oublier pendant ce mandat
qui s'est ouvert en mars dernier
autrement je pense que la communauté
d'agglomération est là pour ça et là
pour valoriser le travail qui doit être
fait dans chacune des communes vous avez
depuis que je suis élu je me suis rendu
dans chacune des communes j'ai visité
quartier par quartier projet j'étudier
projet par projet dans chacune des
communes de 50 donc moi aujourd'hui la
réussite d'une commune fait aussi la
réussite de Saint-Quentin l'homme ne va
pas sans l'autre donc si tu es quelques
projets des nouveaux quartiers à Trappes
il y a beaucoup de logements dans les
projets un nouveau quartier à Trappes à
La Verrière à Élancourt également
dynamiser l'habitat c'est important
dynamiser cet oui mais pas dans
n'importe quel condition parce que
rappelez-vous chaque fois que j'ai
présenté un projet j'ai aussi indiqué
que j'attendais un positionnement fort
définitivement il faut se positionnement
depuis des pouvoirs publics on peut
citer un exemple concret par exemple à
Élancourt tout un quartier est prévu
mais il faut que l'État s'engage sur
l'enfouissement des lignes de tension
exactement c'est pas anecdotique
exactement ce n'est pas anecdotique de
même que alors là c'est le cas sur
Élancourt c'est anormal connaît encore
ses lignes tension mais elles existent
aussi et c'est anormal qu'aujourd'hui le
passe au milieu du quartier du Buisson
sur les hameau mais sur trappes on
travaille aussi sur l'entrée de trappes
à la sortie de l'autoroute A12 donc en
face à la base de loisirs au niveau de
la station-service je sais pas si c'est
son nom mais de qu'à tout le monde voit
bien mais ces terrains si on veut faire
quelque chose il faut y accéder à ce
terrain or aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
donc c'est pour ça que même si nous
sommes sur des projets concrets avec des
développements aussi bien en activité
que en logement tout ceci est quand même
sous réserve que nous puissions avoir
l'aide de des pouvoirs publics pareil
sur la zone des vpk à La Verrière si on
obtient pas le carrefour de la Balme
c'est un quartier enclavé qui ne sera
pas accessible donc c'est un moyen aussi
de faire comprendre que vous prenez des
engagements sans finalement trop vous
mouiller j'ai envie de dire puisque
l'État doit s'engager et par rapport à
la discussion qu'on avait tout à l'heure
vous nous le disiez l'État se désengage
de plus en plus donc il y a peu de
chance de voir l'état amener de l'argent
et permettre la réalisation parce que là
nous sommes nous sommes dans la
construction d'un contrat de
développement territorial demandé par
l'État ou justement il doit faire valoir
ses priorités donc aujourd'hui nous nous
avons travaillé et de ce contrat de
développement territorial va dépendre
aussi le nouveau contrat plan est à
région
aujourd'hui sur les pouvoirs publics sur
l'état pour essayer de faire connaître
aujourd'hui parce que on nous réclame
toujours du développement mais encore
faut-il que tout le monde soit aussi à
la hauteur on peut pas demander sans
aussi s'engager une dernière question le
mot d'ordre s'il y a un mot à retenir
pour cette année pour cette année pour
50 ans en Yvelines pour cette année moi
ce que je souhaite c'est de l'optimisme
mais surtout que chacun comprenne bien
que les moyens de la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 ans de son plus
les mêmes qu'avant merci Michel Laugier
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines et pour terminer cette séquence
je vous propose de revenir sur
l'essentiel de votre cérémonie de vœux
pour 2015 avec ce reportage de Catherine
zulato les grandes orientations à
retenir et il est forcément question
d'économie
j'aurais préféré être Président il y a
10 ans une période dorée ou tout pouvait
être envisagée une phrase prononcée par
Michel Logis Le président de la
Communauté d'Agglomération de 50 ans en
Yvelines à l'occasion des vœux car leur
est aux économies aujourd'hui par
exemple entre l'année 2014 et 2015 je
dois trouver 6 millions d'économies vous
voyez bien que les dotations qui font de
comme neige au soleil pèse énormément
son auto budget c'est pas que le cadre
des tableaux si tu sais le cas dans
toutes les communes c'est pour ça que
j'ai aussi parlé du pacte financier qui
maintient quand même certaines garanties
financières entre la Communauté
d'agglomération et les communes mais
c'est vrai que le maître mot aujourd'hui
il faut trouver il faut faire des
économies on a pu les moyens que nous
avions
d'agglomérations il y a déjà du
changement il y a déjà une autre gestion
il y a déjà notre organisation
administrative aussi et il y a déjà des
directives très précises qui sont donnés
trois audits sont en cours les résultats
seront connus d'ici la fin avril il y a
des certainement des des mutualisation à
faire à certains endroits il y a
certainement des améliorations dans la
période où de toute façon ça a été dit
c'est dit par tout le monde les
ressources sont pour les collectivités
territoriales en baisse mais en même
temps pour nous il y a des aussi des
secteurs qui sont extrêmement importants
essentiels ce serait une erreur par
exemple de toucher sur le secteur
culturel sur le secteur associatif qui
est aujourd'hui crée du lien social crée
du vivre ensemble et qui crée de
l'emploi outre ses économies à réaliser
des rendez-vous d'envergure attendent
l'agglomération des rendez-vous sportifs
comme les Championnats du monde de
cyclisme en février prochain et d'autres
plus politiques comme la refonte du
périmètre de l'agglomération qui
évoluera au 1er janvier 2016 Michel
lobier de rappeler sa vision du Grand
Saint-Quentin accueillant demain les
communes de plaisir les clés Villepreux
mourent pas et Coignières tout en
renforçant ses liens avec le plateau de
Saclay je n'ai qu'une seule ambition
qu'un seul objectif faire de 50 ans en
Yvelines à des symboles de l'excellence
à la française a conclu le président de
l'agglomération
et puis cette autre information
politique dans le cadre des élections
départementales Front de gauche le Parti
de Gauche nouvelle d'homme et Europe
Écologie Les Verts se présenteront sous
une seule et même bannière les
candidatures communes seront présentées
ce jeudi à Saint-Cyr-l'École les
formations appellent à reconstruire une
perspective politique crédible depuis le
7 janvier dernier les Yvelines sont
passées en plan Vigipirate attentat
résultat la présence massive des forces
de l'ordre dans les grands points de
rassemblement un dispositif qui a des
conséquences sur notre quotidien Anthony
Reich pour ce reportage
chaque jour ils sont plusieurs centaines
à patrouiller sur le département depuis
le déclenchement du plan Vigipirate au
niveau attentat les forces de l'ordre se
sont déployées en masse sur les sites
dissensibles une présence quotidienne
qui soulage
c'est très rassurant d'avoir les
policiers qui se promènent le long des
quais c'est très rassurant pour nous
mais on les voit pas Trouiller ce malade
si on a besoin ils sont pas très loin
par cette sensible il faut entendre les
grands rassemblements de fulls comme les
magasins le château de Versailles ou
encore les moyens de transport les lieux
de culte et les entreprises de presse
sont également des zones à surveiller
les policiers qui patrouillent sur la
voie publique ou dans les lieux publics
doivent faire tout d'abord attention aux
éventuels menaces des comportements
atypiques de la part de personnes des
colis piégés par exemple ils doivent
également se rendre disponibles auprès
de la population afin de renseigner et
de rassurer l'élément qui consiste à
devoir rassurer la population et très
important il faut éviter les psychoses
et les peurs
inutiles et irraisonnées chaque matin
l'ensemble des services de sécurité
publique du département se réunit autour
du préfet pour faire un bilan au jour le
jour des actions en place une situation
exceptionnelle qui a eu des conséquences
sur la vie quotidienne des forces de
l'ordre
nous avons par exemple supprimer un
certain nombre de congés nous avons
supprimé les modules de formation et
d'entraînement de même que l'ensemble
des personnels qui pouvaient être
affectés à des tâches de support
technique ont été basculés sur la voie
publique pour maximiser le potentiel de
travail auprès de nos concitoyens depuis
le déclenchement du niveau attentat
l'effet de délinquance sont en baisse
sur les Yvelines
les fêtes de fin d'année sont bel et
bien terminée les décorations sont
enlevées mais on ne sait pas toujours
quoi faire de notre sapin plusieurs
villes proposent de les collecter c'est
le cas de Voisins-le-Bretonneux et qu'il
est valorise dans ses espaces verts se
reportage avec Élodie moine
vos sapins de Noël s'offrent une seconde
vie ici à Voisins-le-Bretonneux pour la
première année après les fêtes 7 points
de collecte ont été aménagées dans la
ville pour recevoir les conifères c'est
un moyen d'éviter que ça traîne
n'importe où mais c'est surtout un moyen
de les valoriser et de les recycler
ensuite dans les différents massifs de
la ville au début on était très modeste
on tablait sur 150 à 200 sapins vu que
c'était la première opération et là nous
en sommes à plus de 800 sapins donc on
peut dire que c'est un succès
seul les sapins non floqués pouvaient
être déposés car le flocage ne se
recycle pas une fois collecté les sapins
sont ensuite tronçonnés et broyés sur
place l'utilisation de ces broyats de
conifères va nous permettre dépendre ce
broyage sur les massifs et ainsi
d'éviter la pousse des mauvaises herbes
et puis de tenir au un peu au chaud
aussi les massifs et ça va finir aussi
par faire un amendement si vous voulez
naturel sur les massifs le produit des
sapins de Noël est ainsi répandu sur les
massifs notamment de bruyères la ville
réfléchit également à revaloriser
d'autres déchets verts issus des 4500
foyers vicinois une démarche qui
s'inscrit plus largement dans une
obligation européenne pour les communes
d'accéder au zéro Phyto c'est-à-dire à
l'arrêt de l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires pesticides et autres
herbicides c'est prévu pour 2020
culture dimanche dernier la compagnie de
danse lyonnaise Pokémon crew s'est
produite sur les planches de la Merise
attrape-elles présentées silence on
tourne un spectacle qui rend hommage au
film muet
de la danse hip-hop présente dans le
cinéma des années 30 difficile à
imaginer pourtant c'est un film de 1928
qui a inspiré la compagnie au kemon crew
on voyait une personne tourner sur la
tête et ça m'a vachement interpellé
parce que on se posait la question d'où
venait ce mouvement d'où il a été créé
une vidéo je pense qu'avec tout le monde
d'accord en expliquant que la danse hip
hop c'est beaucoup inspiré de toutes les
dents c'est surtout de ces années-là
années 20 et 30 tous les comédies
musicales arrivaient en force
silence on tourne c'est l'histoire d'un
making of qui n'a jamais rêvé de voir ce
qu'il se passe derrière une caméra les
Pokémon crew en proposent leur vision on
a imaginé un temps pendant pendant le
tournage d'un film donc on laisse le
spectateur imaginer à sa manière mais
nous par exemple on a imaginé une pause
la pose du par exemple la pose du
comédien après avoir tourné toute la
journée on a imaginé on a essayé de
prendre la place du travelling de moi de
création 5 tableaux et 9 danseurs pour
un savoureux mélange de performance
d'humour et de poésie
les Pokémon crew c'est aussi une
histoire de rue de Battle à ce jour la
compagnie est double championne du monde
championne d'Europe et double championne
de France et entre les compétitions et
la scène c'est parfois le grand écart
c'est différent c'est pas contre plus
compliqué c'est différent parce que
c'est un autre cadre
là il y a un espace à respecter
une écriture chorégraphique une
présence scénique il y a des comptes à
respecter dans ce que la compétition
c'est un peu freestyle comme on dit
c'est rentre tu fais ton passage comme
tu sens avec ton esprit et nous
justement on a envie d'emmener cette
énergie là de la compétition mais sur
scène
cadrer et pourtant tellement fou une
chose est sûre après tout ça on ne
regardera plus un film de la même
manière
du sport pour continuer dimanche dernier
à Guyancourt se tenait une compétition
régionale annuelle du cercle descrimo
programme des duels au sabre auxquels
ont participé 46 escrimeurs âgé de 13 à
16 ans l'occasion d'en savoir un peu
plus sur cette pratique une arme
particulière des images signées Patrick
un salut avant le duel puis une poignée
de main pour se remercier à la fin dans
les screams pour le vaincu comme pour le
vainqueur la première des règles c'est
le respect de l'adversaire pour cette
compétition régionale de sabre à
Guyancourt 46 escrimeurs étaient au
rendez-vous en esprit
il y a donc et le Flores sont deux armes
qu'on appelle des armes de pointe
d'accord le sabre est une arme de
tranchant c'est à dire qu'on peut
toucher avec toute la lame ensuite il y
a des différences de cibles au sabre on
peut par exemple toucher tout ce qui est
au-dessus de la ceinture à l'épée on
peut toucher surtout le corps Gabriel a
16 ans et pour elle la trait de cette
pratique c'est le dynamisme c'est plus
rapide parce qu'à l'épée souvent et au
Fleury
comme c'est de la puce de la précision
il se regarde assez souvent pour essayer
de toucher au bon endroit alors que nous
comme on n'a pas besoin d'appuyer avec
la pointe et qu'on peut toucher avec
tout le sabre c'est plus facile de
toucher donc ça va aller tout je vont
beaucoup plus vite les touches c'est ce
que vont compter les arbitres pour
déterminer le vainqueur chaque touche
données ou reçu ce comptabilise en point
pour évoluer dans cette compétition à
élimination directe des conditions qui
forcent à l'élaboration d'un projet
tactique les principales qualités d'un
sabreur et évidemment la concentration
la force explosive et évidemment la
tactique les qualités c'est être assez
rigoureux et assez concentré aussi on a
besoin d'être concentré dans ce soir ces
valeurs d'harmonie du corps et de
l'esprit sont les sens même de l'escrime
Gabriel quant à elle montra sur la
seconde marche du podium
fin du journal bonne soirée je vous
retrouve demain même horaires pour une
nouvelle édition d'information locale